وفي اسرائيل قتل شخص واحد واصيب ثلاثه عشر
بجروح اثر سقوط صاروخ اطلق من قطاع غزه في
مدينه روحفوت جنوب
واعلنت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تعليق
الدراسه في المدينه بعد تعرضها للقصف وقال
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي خللا تقنيا
بمنظومه القبه الحديديه حاله دون اعتراض
الصاروخ الذي اصاب المبنى في لحافات امس
الخميس
كيف تبدو الصوره من الجانب الاسرائيلي
57 اسرائيليا يحتاج للعلاج منذ بدايه هذا
التصعيد معظمهم في حالاتي هلا طبعا هنالك
قتيل اسرائيلي في الصاروخ الذي اصيبت فيه
مدينه ريحوفت اضافه الى ثمانيه اسرائيليين
جرحى جرحوا بعضهم متوسطه لكن العدد
الاجمالي لمن قدم لهم الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
العلاج وصل الى سبعه وخمسين او 57
اسرائيليا الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح هذا
اليوم وسيله اعترف بان خللا فنيا اصاب
منظومه القبه الحديديه وهو ما ادى الى فشل
هذه المنظومه في انقراض الصاروخ الذي اصاب
المبنى المؤلف من طوابق عده في مدينه
ريحوفت وادى الى مقتل اسرائيلي واصابه
ثمانيه اخرين بجروح بعضهم وصفت جراحهم
بانها متوسطه لا شك في ان هنالك تحقيق في
هذا السياق من جانبي سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
ومن الواضح بان هنالك اختلاف في طبيعه
الخلل الذي اصاب هذه المنظومه من مقارنه
مع الخلل الفني الذي اصابها الاسبوع
الماضي ذلك ان الاسبوع الماضي الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحدث عن خلل تقني في اعتراض
الصواريخ وكان واضحا بان الخلل يتعلق ربما
بالمنظومه الرادريه القادره على تحديد
اماكن السقوط الصواريخ ذلك ان المنظومه
تعترض الصواريخ التي تعتقد بانها او تحدد
بانها ستسقط في مناطق ماهوله ولا تعترض
الصواريخ التي تسقط في مناطق مفتوحه
وبالتالي اصابه مباني في حينه كان مؤشرا
على ان هذه المنظومه اصيبت بخلل لكن ما
حدث بالامس هو ان صاروخ تمير الذي يطلق في
اطار اعتراضي الصواريخ الاتيه من قطاع غزه
اطلق بالفعل من هذه المنظومه لكنه
لم يتمكن من اصابه الهدف وبالتالي واضح
بان هذه المره
الخلل يبدو انه نابع من المنظومه
الصاروخيه وليس من المنظومه
الراديري الرادريه